scheduling change for week seven
buccaneers raiders out of prime time
seahawks cardinals into prime time on
nbc now look i just said earlier this
week we need more kyler murray in prime
time no matter what the score is i love
watching any game with kyler murray in
it i am spitting with his skill set
speed awareness agility all in one like
the nfl has never seen but this isn't
happening because somebody said hey we
want more kyler murray in prime time
this is happening because the raiders
are the latest team to have a covet 19
outbreak some of the details that are
out there
are extremely troubling when you
consider the lessons supposedly learned
by everyone in the aftermath of the
tennessee titans situation peter from a
couple of weeks ago the idea that
guys were in the facility without masks
on trent brown the guy who tested
positive not having his tracking device
so they can't figure out who had close
contact with him the entire offensive
line sent home as a precaution you know
this is the first time we have an
outbreak plus enhanced protocols that
basically send everyone out of the
building who may have been in close
contact with the people who tested
positive and the raiders are going to
have a hell of a time putting a
competitive team on the field on sunday
i don't think the league is going to
give them a break and say
well you don't have guys available we'll
give you you know a game on tuesday
instead when maybe you do or we'll make
this the first game of our 18th week
because both the raiders and the buck
well the raiders have had their buy um
so i it's not like you can reschedule it
to a later week in the season
i think i think it's going to be very
interesting to see how the league deals
with the raiders right now their game is
set for 405 on sunday
and
i again don't know how much of a break
they're gonna get
even if they have a bunch of guys who
aren't allowed to come back as a
precaution that they may develop covet
19.
yeah the bucks um are really going to
get stuck with this mic honestly and you
knew that you know we've been saying all
along this season is going to be unfair
uh and this might be the first big
example because you're right this is the
first game that cannot be rescheduled by
pushing around a bunch of buys
uh because you you know one team has has
had its buy and so you there's no
wiggle room there
but i agree with you i think the nfl is
is sign at least as of yesterday was
very much inclined to try to play this
game some point
no later than uh tuesday but i i'll just
say one other thing
when the nfl created this eight person
i call it sort of kitchen cabinet
advisory board to roger goodell you know
the bill paulians and troy palamalu's
and isaac bruce's
to just basically ask him okay what do
you think what should a team have to do
this was the specific example
that was given to me what if an entire
position group is unable to play
and you know are we going to
take the risk
of putting let's say a franchise
quarterback at risk if the entire
offensive line can't play
that is why i think in the next two days
uh you know the nfl is going to have
some significant decisions to make about
this team and this game and the next day
really but mike you also mentioned trent
brown and the tracking device
in my opinion if it is found
that trent brown was not wearing his
tracking device uh on
even if it's only one occasion okay
that should be in my opinion a heavier
sanction on them
than will be on the tennessee titans
because there are some things that
absolutely categorically without
exception you have to do you walk into
your facility every day and the first
thing you do is you take a covet test
you get your temperature taken and you
put on the tracking device period end of
story
if you weren't wearing your tracking
device
trent brown has to get has to get fined
heavy the raiders have to get fined
heavier
that's that is totally absurd you talk
about the wild west
that is a ridiculous
uh
you know evasion of protocol by the
raiders and by trent brown if it is true
and what a shock what a shock if it
turns out being the raiders given the
video we saw a few weeks ago of all the
guys without masks in a confined space
with a bunch of people without masks the
raiders have been on the edge of this
all along and i'm surprised it took as
long as it did for the raiders to have
some sort of an outbreak and you know
what it's fitting if john gruden is not
buttoning up his roster getting his
locker room to comply and he's going to
have his opportunity to face the tampa
bay buccaneers undermined because of it
he gets what he deserves peter because
it ultimately comes down to him he's the
one that needs to make sure that his
guys are doing what they need to do some
coaches are some coaches aren't he's not
and he's going to potentially be
undermanned when it's time to get a
little revenge on the tampa bay
buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports